bonsoir françois-xavier bellamy merci
d'être notre invité ce soir vous êtes
philosophe essayiste et la tête de liste
donc pour les européennes des
républicains je le disais aujourd'hui
vous êtes à peu près à 13,13 et demi
pour cent donc je dirais presque dix
points derrière les deux ceux qui sont
les favoris des sondages
à cette heure ci un jeu précise
absolument et le vous êtes le troisième
invité notre dispositif spécial
européenne qui nous amènera au 23 mai le
23 mai c'est l'heure de notre grand
débat sur bfm tv avec tous les avec la
plus grande partie des candidats et
jusqu à 19h50 on est ensemble vous
répondrai aux questions de sophie pedder
qui est la chef du bureau parisien de
l'hebdomadaire britannique d'économistes
évidemment on va parler du bric site 1
et puis comme chaque tête de liste vous
serez aussi interrogé par un opposant il
s'agira de thierry mariani qu et ancien
ministre de nicolas sarkozy et qui a
rejoint la liste du rassemblement
national
alors avant de parler de sujets
précisément européen d'abord ce grand
débat et cette issue qu'est ce que vous
en attendez d'emmanuel macron d annonce
qu' on est en train maintenant d'essayer
de deviner dans les jours qui viennent
d'abord on en attendant effectivement
une issue il faut absolument qu'on
puisse avoir un vrai débat sur la
question européenne et je vous remercie
beaucoup de votre invitation pour parler
de l'europe il faut vraiment qu'on
puisse se consacrer aux grands choix qui
sont devant les français sur l'avenir de
l'europe aidera ces moments passés très
vite parce que vous voulez passer alors
je ne comprends pas que le président de
l'apa bien sûr mais je ne comprends pas
que le président de la république et lui
même dépassé le calendrier qu'il s'était
fixé pourtant au début de ce grand débat
je ne comprends pas non plus je dois le
dire
en écoutant edouard philippe le premier
ministre qu'il ait fallu plusieurs mois
de débats partout en france pour se
rendre compte qu'il y avait par exemple
un problème fiscal qui pèse sur le
pouvoir d'achat
donc oui maintenant il faut des
décisions il faut pouvoir avancer vers
les choix que le gouvernement présentera
ou que le président de la république
assumera quoi qu'il en soit il faut
absolument qu'on puisse avancer
maintenant sortir de ce grand débat de
manière à pouvoir se tourner vers ce
sujet européen qui est si fondamental
alors dans ce qg européen vous présente
comme c'est lui qui a réveillé la droite
qui a mais en même qui l'a même en
partie réconcilier comment l'expliquez
vous d'abord je crois qu'on on me prête
beaucoup en réalité c'est vraiment un
travail d'équipé j'ai eu la joie d'être
investi avec à
c'est vrai elle avec arnaud danjean et
depuis deux mois maintenant nous sommes
sur le terrain en permanence pour parler
aux français qui attendent justement
qu'on vienne leur parler d'europe c'est
vrai que au début quand j'ai pris la
mission qui m'a été confiée par par ce
mouvement
nous étions à 8 % dans les sondages et
on disait que notre famille politique
pouvait passer derrière nicolas dupont
aignan je suis heureux qu'on ait eu
cette dynamique qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de relever la tête je ne me
suis pas laissé impressionner par les
difficultés du début je ne me laisse pas
non plus impressionner par cette petite
dynamique l'essentiel est devant nous il
faut qu'on puisse continuer de parler du
fond de parler de rupture c'est ce qui
compte néanmoins vous parvenez pas
dépasser pour le moment un certain seuil
vous restez un lointain troisième si
vous permettez parce que je me demande
quand même si enfin en tout cas dans les
dents les analyser sondages on voit que
les déçus de françois fillon qui ont
voté en 2017 pour emmanuel macron ne
sont pas tous revenus chez vous et 1 sur
2 pas continuent à voter pour la liste
l'oiseau en l'occurrence et je me
demande si dans le fond il notamment les
seniors par exemple dans les seniors
vous n'avez pas encore conquis les
seniors une partie d'entre eux je monte
c'est parce que dans votre programme il
n'y a pas trop de ressemblances avec
celui d' emmanuel macron sur l'économie
sur la protection de l'europe sur les
frontières là à l'instant même où vient
de voir que à l'elysée la france annonce
qu'elle votera lundi à bruxelles contre
l'ouverture de négociations commerciales
entre l'union européenne et les etats
unis
bon c'est aussi votre position par
exemple sur l'économie fallait pas
pardonnez moi ça n'est pas celle qui a
été la voix de la france lors des
dernières discussions où effectivement
la france le gouvernement français a
accepté l'ouverture de ces négociations
dont il ya aussi un en même temps qui
parfois peut poser problème la merci on
vous laissera probablement ils sont
entre alors quelle est la différence
pourquoi ça ne va plus à la différence
de la liste dans marche d'abord nous
avons un programme nous avons un projet
clair fait soixante quinze propositions
aujourd'hui nous ne savons pas
exactement sur quelle piste s'engage la
candidature dans marche si ce n'est la
lettre des manuels macron peut-être se
rassurent un programme bien sûr en tous
les cas nous nous avons un projet clair
et nous le défendons depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant la deuxième chose
c'est que c'est vrai vous avez raison
nous n'avons pas réussi encore à rallier
à nous tous ceux qui pourraient se
reconnaître pourtant
notre projet pour une raison très simple
c'est que emmanuel macron comme marine
le pen ont installé l'idée que le
clivage qui restait c'était le clivage
entre les progressistes les populistes
et beaucoup croient à mon avis à tort
qu'il faut choisir son camp
dans ce schéma binaire nous nous disons
aux français qu'ils ont le droit de
choisir pour l'europe qu'ils veulent et
je pense en particulier bien sûr par
exemple à tous les retraités qui sont
directement les victimes de la politique
menée par emmanuel macron au cours des
derniers mois qui aujourd'hui se disent
que peut être s'ils ne veulent pas voter
pour le rassemblement national ils n'ont
pas d'autre choix que de choisir la
liste des manuels macron à ces électeurs
là nous disons que nous voulons faire
exister un vrai débat européen
parce qu'il faut que les français aient
le choix de l'europe qu'ils veulent
construire et ce projet que nous portons
il va dans ce débat permettre aux
français de choisir par exemple sur les
retraités bas il est possible que
manière ma croix annonce la réindexation
des retraites sur l'inflation et qui
baissent et qui supprime la csg sur les
retraites donc dans le fond il peut
peut-être les récupère on sera très
heureux que sur ce sujet comme sur bien
d'autres dans ce débat européen emmanuel
macron et ceux qui l'entourent se
mettent à adopter les positions que nous
défendons depuis des mois maintenant
maintenant ce qui compte encore une fois
je ne vais pas spéculer sur ce que
monsieur mâcon va annoncer dans deux
jours c'est qu'on puisse ou dans
quelques jours je ne sais pas ce qui
compte vraiment c'est qu'on puisse
parler de l'europe parlait ce débat
européen et emmanuel macron dans son
discours d'athènes dans son discours de
la sorbonne a développé une vision très
fédéraliste de l'europe
il l'a rappelé dans la lettre qu'il a
écrite en créant en proposant de créer
toute une série d' agences de comité
nous ne croyons pas à cette europe qui
ne fonctionnent plus qui s'éloigne des
citoyens nous voulons une europe qui
fasse de nouveau la preuve de son
efficacité au service des peuples
européens
j'ai une petite question juste de
politique intérieure française mais en
même temps évidemment elle peut toucher
celle sur la privatisation des aéroports
de paris si vous étiez parlementaire est
ce que vous seriez associé à la demande
de référendum
je me serais opposé en effet à cette
privatisation non pas parce que nous
serions contre les privatisations ce
n'est pas mon cas d'un programme de
françois fillon n'est d'accord la
question c'est de savoir dans quelle
perspective on fait des privatisations
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'on ne
fait ces privatisations pour les négocie
mal d'ailleurs et de façon trop rapide
que parce qu'on n'a pas su réformer
l'état le programme de françois fillon
s'était d'abord un programme très
complet et précis pour réformer la
dépense publique qui aujourd'hui n'a pas
baissé dans notre pays emmanuel macron
dépense plus que françois hollande au
même stade de son quinquennat
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme il
ne fait pas d'économies comme la
pression fiscale est la plus importante
au monde et qu'il n'a plus le levier sur
ce volet là eh bien il est contraint de
céder de façon hâtive
ces éléments qui sont pourtant
importants et qui mérite qu'on y accorde
une vraie considération la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris
si elle se conclut dans les mêmes termes
que celle de l'air pur si elle se
conclut dans les mêmes termes que celle
de l'aéroport de toulouse qui avait été
cédée il y a quelques années par
emmanuel macron ministre de l'économie
alors il ya de quoi s'inquiéter parce
que la cour des comptes a récemment
montré que cette privatisation avait été
une catastrophe
et donc il faut absolument que nous
puissions lorsque nous réfléchissons sur
le périmètre d'intervention de l'état
le faire non pas sous la pression que
nous impose une mauvaise gestion des
dépenses publiques mais dans une vision
stratégique de ce sur quoi l'état doit
vraiment rester engagés alors je le
répète dans un instant on va parler que
sophie pedder et notamment d'europe et
de briques site met tout de suite
thierry mariani et en direct avec nous
et donc il est un ancien ministre de
nicolas sarkozy qui a rejoint la liste
de marine le pen en fait de jordan
bardella bon sortir et mariani vous
voulez interpellé françois xavier
bellamy bonsoir bonsoir monsieur bonsoir
monsieur bellamy jeu j'écoute vote le
programme des républicains que je
connais bien et ce qui me gêne c'est que
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un programme
à paris et des votes à bruxelles qui
sont différents et si vous me permettez
je voudrais simplement aborder le sujet
de l'immigration
je constate que le discours à paris
c'est contre le pacte de marrakech
mais en avril 18 la résolution qui
participait à l'élaboration du pacte de
marrakech a été votée à une exception
près par tous les députés des
républicains en octobre 17 c'est la mise
en place de la répartition des migrants
qui là aussi a été votée par les
républicains en mars 19 c'est le
financement par l'union européenne du
regroupement familial
alors la situation de l'immigration en
europe qui est aujourd'hui critiqué à
juste titre c'est aussi le bilan de la
majorité européenne le tpe dans laquelle
vous appartenez
alors ma question est simple à chaque
fois là des beaux discours à paris mais
qu'est ce qui ferait que cette fois
enfin la liste à l'acte dans laquelle
vous êtes aurait le même discours à
paris et les mêmes vote à bruxelles
monsieur mariani merci pour votre
question je ferai simplement
l'objection à votre objection que
d'abord la plupart des éléments que vous
me rapportez sont réformés mentalement
inexactes sur le pacte de marrakech il
est parfaitement évident et chacun
pourra le vérifier en s'y référant que
les parlementaires de notre famille
politique n'ont pas voté au parlement
européen en faveur du pacte de marrakech
et nous proposons dans notre projet de
dénoncer ce pacte de marrakech qui
contient en effet une vision de la
question migratoire que nous ne
partageons absolument pas sur la
question de la répartition des quotas de
migrants la question de la répartition
des migrants en europe
elle a été exigée notamment par vos
alliés par par exemple monsieur salvini
qu'ils disaient et à raison que l'italie
avait porté sur elle la totalité du
poids de l'impuissance européenne face à
la crise migratoire
nous nous disons aujourd'hui c'est vrai
l'europe a fauté elle a pensé
répartition avant de penser protection
elle a pensé à cette répartition des
migrants sur le sol européen comme le
fait d'ailleurs monsieur macron
aujourd'hui au lieu de penser au
renforcement des frontières extérieures
de l'europe et de ce point de vue là
monsieur mariani
je vous objecterez pardonnez moi que les
parlementaires du rassemblement national
au cours des dernières années ont voté
contre tout ce qui pouvait permettre de
renforcer l'union européenne face aux
défis migratoires contre la création du
pnr qui permet d'identifier ceux qui
volent dans le ciel européen contre
l'établissement de contrôles
systématiques aux frontières extérieures
de l'europe contre le renforcement de
l'agencé frontex
aujourd'hui marine le pen décrit pour se
justifier comme une agence qui
accueillent les migrants
alors quel est le levier qui permet de
lutter contre l'immigration illégale en
europe
monsieur mariani vous avez été très
longtemps membre de notre famille
politique ne me fais pas s'il vous plaît
un procès en incohérence pendant des
années de votre vie politique vous avez
dit que marine le pen était un danger et
une impasse aujourd'hui oui c'est vrai
nous savons que la droite n'a pas
toujours tout réussi nous savons que le
bilan de la construction européenne
n'est pas totalement positif
évidemment que beaucoup d'erreurs ont
été commises si je suis là si je
m'engage maintenant c'est pour tenter de
relever le défi d'un vrai changement en
europe qui nous permettra de renforcer
l'europe plutôt que de la laisser se
discréditer encore et il n'y a je crois
que le ppe qui puisse mener cette action
aujourd'hui j'ai une petite question
vous avez vu qu'il ya une polémique où
il ya eu une polémique autour des propos
de christophe castaner qu'il a rectifiée
ensuite en disant oui
sur les ong il a rectifié en disant
qu'elle joue un rôle essentiel pour
apporter de l'aide aux migrants
méditerranée mais il avait dit qu'elle
pouvait se faire complice de passeur et
il les avait appelés à avoir une
attitude responsable pour vous ces ong
elles sont complices ou au contraire
sincère factuellement elles le sont
actuellement elle le son son compte avec
sans doute avec les meilleures
intentions du monde
elles permettent aux pacers d'assurer la
dernière étape de leur business c'est à
dire de cette traite d'êtres humains qui
par le mirage d'un eldorado que nous
vendons à des jeunes africains les
conduit dans cette impasse qu'il trouve
aujourd'hui en europe
factuellement il y avait frontex l'avait
montré je l'avais dit d'ailleurs il ya
quelques mois dans une autre et
montlouis dit d'applis vous utilisez le
même mot c'est en fait aucun fait qu'il
y avait un lien et qui est ces liens ont
été démontrée notamment par frontex que
monsieur mariani
en un mot monsieur mariani répondez à à
la réponse de françois xavier bellamy je
répondrai monsieur bel ami que j'ai
jamais dit par exemple que le député a
l'air avaient voté le pacte de marrakech
est pas là mais simplement vérifier en
avril
merci de la résolution qui participe à
l'élaboration la résolution qui
participe à l'élaboration du pacte de
marrakech où le parlement européen dit
c'est un pacte nécessaire et tout a été
votée à une exception près par
l'ensemble des députés de votre groupe
et dernier aujourd'hui en réalité ce se
conduit frontex conduit aujourd'hui
comme une agence d'accueil on sait très
bien que ça n'a empêché aucune entrée
regardez ce qui se passe en italie
c'est le jour où l'europe d'hier a très
clairement plus aucun bateau clandestin
de migrants accostera en europe
s'il ne respecte pas la loi est bien là
effectivement on aura des résultats
mais oui monsieur mariani merci
exactement pardonnez moi ce que nous
disons aussi évidemment et c'est
exactement la raison pour laquelle nous
avons besoin de renforcer frontex et
c'est vrai de réorienter l'action
européenne en la matière une question de
ce fip et d'air et ensuite on se
retrouvera après la pause lorsque la
pourquoi vous emmerde et c'est fini
merci beaucoup merci thierry mariani
sophie pedder vous êtes donc la la la la
patronne de dix économistes à paris et
le bric si c'est évidemment le grand
sujet européen question écouté hier soir
président français s'est retrouvé assez
isolée parmi les 26 en s'opposant à une
longue extension pour le brésil est-ce
que
vous trouvez que c'est une bonne la
bonne position à prendre ou est-ce qu'il
fallait pas donner plus de temps au
gouvernement britannique aux
parlementaires britanniques qui ont pris
le contrôle sur le sujet pour trouver un
accord et pour éviter le new deal pas
excellent
vous avez tout à fait raison emmanuel
macron s'est montrée isolés sur la scène
européenne vous nous demandiez quels
étaient les points de désaccord avec lui
on voit là un très important
nous nous croyons que le bric site n'est
pas seulement un problème pour les
britanniques c'est un problème aussi
pour les européens pour les français et
notre responsabilité c'est de ne pas
être idéologue d'être vraiment
pragmatique et de faire en sorte que les
intérêts des français soit préservé
voire d'une longue extension vos
horizons femmes nous disent en extension
celle des gens nous lisons comme michel
barnier l'a dit d'ailleurs pendant des
années et pendant des mois qui se sont
écoulés tout plutôt qu'une sortie sans
accord parce qu'une sortie sans accord
serait une catastrophe pour les
britanniques mais aussi pour nos propres
acteurs nos entreprises nos pêcheurs en
particulier et nous avons la
responsabilité de défendre cette
solution on reste ensemble on se
retrouve dans un instant et on continue
[Musique]
vous
regardez votre programme avec toyota
business plus l'alternative hybride pour
les entreprises
toyota business plus grandir avec vous
retrouvez l'appli bfm tv sur votre
mobile découvrez les sacs les sto
réutilisables et costauds ils sont
géniaux
la sto le jardinage en un geste ô
sortait des sentiers battus oser des
combinaisons inattendues
pensez-vous mouvement différemment dans
ces hybrides vivait suzuki l'efficacité
de la technologie hybride suzuki
c'est ici et maintenant suzuki l'hybride
à partir de 13 milles 740 euros sur
l'application mobile
ou le site internet
envoyer de l'argent avec western union
et rester connecter à vos proches et en
ce moment téléchargez l'application et
profiter de 0 euro de frais de transfert
pour votre première transaction western
union
enfin un sac qui sait se tenir au peuple
de l'est ce taux le jardinage en un
geste ô
[Musique]
somfy vous accompagne vers un meilleur
habitat depuis 50 ans
[Musique]
et pour ses 50 ans homme qui vous
rembourse jusqu'à 150 euros sur l'achat
de produits de sécurité
avez vous déjà été malade car votre
appareil de pression positive continue
était sale so clean est le premier
dispositif médical au monde entièrement
automatisée qui détruit vite et
efficacement 99,9 pour cent de tous les
germes présents dans les appareils de
ppc so clean est compatible avec tous
les masques des appareils de ppc les
plus courants avec so clean oublier la
corvée quotidienne de nettoyage manuel
pour détruire les germes essayé so clean
pendant 30 nuit sans engagement la
livraison est gratuite
appelez dès maintenant le 0 800 1 237
680 ou consulter le site so clean points
comme so clean est un dispositif médical
servante à détruire les bactéries des
appareils de pression positive continue
pour les patients souffrant d'apnée du
sommeil
[Applaudissements]
vous avez remarqué dans la vie on ne
maîtrise pas toujours tout mais au moins
avec écho du crédit agricole budget
maîtrisé écossais 2 euros par mois
seulement
échos du crédit agricole c'est une carte
qu'une appli est une agence pour 2 euros
par mois points
rendez-vous vite sur ecover point find
[Musique]
you ko
il
je l'aimé
hennion
[Musique]
et il
problème de stock appelé repar'stores
trouver le centre le plus proche de chez
vous sur repar'stores points comme devis
gratuit et interventions rapides
problème de stores appelé repar'stores
chez la vie claire depuis 70 ans
notre indépendance nous permet de
dessiner une autre pion à bientôt chez
la vie claire halflings accompagne la
révolution des télécommunications
d'entreprise avec ses offres de
communications unifiées et de fibre
optique très haut débit elle fanning les
télécommunications d'aujourd'hui pour
les entreprises exigeantes maman qu'est
ce qu'on mange ce soir de l'eau
seulement de l'eau vous ne nourrissez
pas vos enfants qu'avec de l'eau alors
pourquoi le faire avec vos plantes
donnez leur de l'engrais plantes
fleuries terre qui les gêne pour des
plantes visiblement plus belle en sept
jours votre jardin a besoin d'amour et
de fertiles et gênes vous êtes sûr de ne
pas vouloir essayer essayer avant
d'acheter c'est important avec le
service à l'essai de capifrance soyez
sûr de votre achat immobilier capifrance
de 800 conseillers votre service vous
avez vu cet homme d'ailleurs son
ordinateur fait 20 minutes qu'il essaie
de mettre à jour son logiciel de paye
vous savez qu'il va devoir payer juste
pour cette dernière version du mauvais
on vous doris on n'a ni bellis monsieur
potier donc j'ai aussi dû bout je vais
aller expliquer notre cher voisin qu'il
existe un logiciel de paie et rh 100%
web actualisé en temps réel sans version
ni surcoût pourrait faire comme ça on
sera demain monsieur gautier demain à
doris j'adhère libellis de monde ou
demain
désolé pour le retard j'ai perdu ma
carte
impossible de retirer de l'argent par un
centime sur moi et la personne pour
m'aider évidemment tu sais qu'à une
banque qui aurait pu t'aider une banque
will crédit mutuel avec sa nouvelle
appli tu veux retirer de l'argent avec
ton smartphone en plus un service
gratuit pas quelle idée aussi de perdre
cette carte je te présente mon père
nouvelle appli du crédit mutuel avec
heroes très gratuit crédit mutuel une
banque qui appartient à ses clients ça
change tout la revente facile avec pour
les voitures point fr en de votre
voiture pour le fun on n'est pas trop
mal évaluer votre voiture en ligne
gratuitement et wendel a dans une agence
proche de chez vous vendez votre voiture
point fr et quelle est la valeur de
votre voiture bondée votre voiture point
fr je t'aime où es tu
[Musique]
sapphire orange enthousiasme
saphirs roses bonheur saphirs jaunes
énergie sapphire violet mystique
émeraude vers espoir rubis rouge passion
saphir bleu harmonie je t'aime mon amour
mauboussin
capsule d'émotion
[Musique]
regardez votre programme avec toyota
business plus l'alternative hybride pour
les entreprises
toyota business plus grandir avec vous
on se retrouve avec vous françois-xavier
abelhamid en tête de liste des
républicains pour cette émission sophie
pedder du des économistes continuent à
vous poser question sur le break site on
a commencé votre courrier vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que vous aurez été en
faveur d'une extension plus longue
plongeon inédit mais le risque existe
mais au moins les sports 2 d'avoir le
royaume uni comme partenaire difficile
au sein de l'europe
comment on dans ce cas je dirais ça
c'est pas est-ce que c'est pas mieux
finalement de laisser de laisser partir
les britanniques
les britanniques ont pris un engagement
très clair celui de ne pas paralyser de
ne pas perturber les institutions
européennes je crois que c'est une
évidence
maintenant ce qui est certain c'est que
l'incertitude actuelle
elle pèse sur les britanniques beaucoup
plus que sur les européens
les européens ont été capables avec le
travail de michel barnier de parler
d'une seule voix tout au long de ce
débat aujourd'hui
rien n'empêche notre pays de fonctionner
une relation d'être utile et opérante
alors que si demain nous sortons sans
accord ce sont des dizaines de milliers
de traces de travailleurs liés à la
pêche qui vont devoir rester à quai des
dizaines de milliers de familles qui
sont menacées c'est une industrie qui
risque d'être paralysée à examiner le
lien entre nos états s'ils restent des
anglais des britanniques dans l'europe
qu'ils ont un commissaire qui l'ont des
députés tout en voulant sortir puisque
le référendum d'été sur le break 6 est
ce qu'il n'y ait pas de bloquer le
fonctionnement de l'europe
bien sûr évidemment je le redis nous
sommes tous d'accord là dessus il aurait
mille fois mieux valu parvenir à un
accord et il faut maintenant que le
britannique puisse régler enfin ce
problème qui est d'abord chez eux qui
est d'abord à londres et non pas à
bruxelles ou à strasbourg mais tout vaut
mieux encore une fois dans cette
situation pénible qu une sortie sans
accord et je crois qu'on serait
irresponsable comme responsables
politiques n'ont pas encore une fois
vis-à-vis des britanniques mais
vis-à-vis de nos propres citoyens des
français nous serions irresponsables de
faire un pas en avant vers le précipice
qui est sous nos pas devant cette sortie
sans accord faisant l'hypothèse que le
royaume uni sorte à un moment ou un
autre
j'ai une question pour vous sur la
défense la défense européenne parce que
le partenaire principal de la france
finalement dans cette matière c'est le
royaume est né vous avez
parler de l'autonomie stratégie de
l'europe vous êtes contre une armée
européenne qu'elle serait éventuellement
l'articulation entre le royaume uni
sortie de l'union européenne l'union
européenne et le temps qui lui garantit
finalement de de la défense de notre
continent qui est une garantie mais qui
ne doit pas être la seule et on voit
bien à quel point le défi devant nous
c'est de construire une autonomie
stratégique européenne ça fait trop
longtemps qu'on en parle et qu'on n'a
pas réussi à la construire
dans cette perspective bien sûr le
royaume uni ce sera évidemment un acteur
il ya des pays qui ne font pas partie de
l'union européenne et qui sont pourtant
des partenaires privilégiés de l'union
européenne et avec lesquels bien sûr
nous devons continuer de travailler et
il faut évidemment qu'en matière de
défense nous ne nous privions pas de
l'apport incontournable des britanniques
nous le savons très bien nous sommes peu
de pays en europe à avoir des armes est
capable d'intervenir militairement sur
le terrain c'est aussi pour cette raison
là que le concept d'armée européenne ne
pourrait pas fonctionner l'allemagne par
exemple à une culture militaire très
différente de la nôtre du fait de son
histoire et la repenser comment faire
exactement concrètement ça veut dire est
ce que roy fait ça veut dire d'abord
avoir une vision aujourd'hui seuls
l'otan a vraiment une vision une
doctrine d'emploi seul l'otan est
capable de faire prévaloir aussi des
intérêts industriels à partir de cette
vision
l'europe de la défense est trop faible
parce que nous n'avons pas réussi à
mettre tous les partenaires européens de
notre côté nous nous disons très
clairement que sur un sujet comme
celui-ci il faut mettre en oeuvre des
blocs de coopération renforcée on n'a
pas besoin d'avancer à 27 si on veut
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre des réponses à
ces problèmes qui se posent aujourd'hui
et peut-être c'est d'ailleurs un sujet
construire une europe de la défense avec
quelques pays qui voudront avancé je
pense à l'allemagne par exemple avec
laquelle on est en train de commencer à
penser
l'avion de combat du futur je pense à
d'autres pays qui pourront être
intéressé par le développement d'une
filière sur les drones avancer dans ce
projet d'une europe de la défense avec
des blocs de foie serait ce qu'à fait
actuellement en allemagne may résidents
macron avec lady d
l'initiative d'intervention européenne
qui effectivement lit la grande-bretagne
perspectives à
à une organisation coopération avec
d'autres états oui vous avez tout à fait
raison il ya des choses il ya des choses
dans leur nombre est bien sûr il ya des
choses qui vont dans le bon sens jusqu'à
dire mais cela étant dit précision
malgré tout une chose on peut pas parler
d'armée européenne et faire des grands
mots comme ça et simultanément ne pas
avoir de vision stratégique en matière
industrielle
emmanuel macron est celui qui a accepté
de céder la branche énergie d'alstom a
de général elektriks et aujourd'hui ce
sont nos turbines nucléaires qui sont
entretenues par des américains en
particulier celle du charles de gaulle
où nos sous marins nucléaires parler
d'une armée européenne ça ne sert à rien
si c'est pour laisser se défaire les
moyens de notre souveraineté en matière
de défense sur le plan industriel j'ai
deux petites questions car le temps
presse j'ai remarqué dans votre dans vos
75 que proposition qui est à peu près
une trentaine de propositions autour de
l'identité de
du terrorisme de la culture les
propositions économiques à partir c'est
à partir des 30 des 30 la 30e 35e
propositions la proposition sur l'avenir
c'est à dire vous parlez de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est la 65e
propositions sur 75 et au début vous
visez vous évoquez deux d'inscrire les
racines judéo chrétiennes de l'europe
ainsi que l'héritage gréco romain et
celui des lumières dans les traités mais
vous qui êtes un philosophe un fin
lettré vous ne vous trouvez aucune trace
de l'islam dans l'histoire européenne
vous ne vous souvenez pas de la présence
de philosophes ou de mathématiciens
musulmans dans l'histoire européenne
mais si bien sûr d'ailleurs l'europe
n'est pas faite d'un seul bloc elle
n'est pas faite d'une seule histoire
cela étant dit nous serions fous de
tomber dans une forme de relativisme qui
nous condamnerait à ne pas voir
l'évidence c'est à dire la prégnance
très forte de certaines traditions de
certains courants qui ont irrigué ce qui
est aujourd'hui l'esprit européen
je n'ai aucun problème pour reconnaître
tant que ça parce que par exemple jeunes
et les remettent je n'ai aucun problème
pour reconnaître par exemple que les
pays du maghreb ont une histoire et une
identité qui est très liée à l'islam ça
n'enlève rien au fait que cette histoire
et j'ai aussi marqué par la présence de
tce tient bien sûr mais pourquoi ce que
je veux dire c'est pourquoi serions nous
capables de reconnaître que les pays du
maghreb sont des pays musulmans est
incapable de dire que nous avons une
histoire singulière qui nous lie à la
tradition judéo-chrétienne
ça n'enlève rien au fait que des gens
venus de partout ont apporté leur
contribution à cette histoire magnifique
et d'ailleurs c'est aussi la condition
pour se tourner et vous parliez d'avenir
pour se tourner vers l'avenir
ce n'est qu'en s'appuyant sur cette
histoire que nous pourrons reconstruire
le lien qui unit notre société non pas à
partir d'une confession on n'a pas
besoin d'être chrétien pour dire qu'il y
a en europe quelque chose qui est liée à
cet héritage singulier et cette capacité
de nommer ce que nous sommes c'est ce
dont nous avons besoin je le dis comme
enseignant comme prof de philo qui a
trop vu naître cette france archipel
dont nous parle jérôme fourquet avec des
jeunes qui grandissent en france mais
qui ne savent pas ce qu'est être
français c'est cela qu'il faut partager
de nouveau en france et en europe pour
préparer notre avenir
dernière question la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme a rendu un avis
consultatif aujourd'hui elle estime que
la filiation des enfants nés d'une mère
porteuse à l'étranger donc par gpa doit
être reconnue et propose par exemple la
piste de l'adoption pour cela qu'en
pensez vous
je suis très préoccupé de cette
situation parce qu'on voit au fond que
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
elle veut aujourd'hui imposer à notre
droit national consultatif mais malgré
tout c'est un avis qui est pris par la
france d'ailleurs est-ce que c'est tout
à fait normal que nous ayons besoin de
demander son avis pour pouvoir nous
déterminer dans cette situation
au fond on voit bien qu'il s'agit de
contourner le droit
nous avons le devoir de dire ce que nous
croyons juste et la question de la
gestation pour autrui est une question
éthique absolument fondamental c'est la
dignité humaine c'est la marchandisation
du corps qui est en jeu d'autres pays
que nous ont décidé d'introduire la
gestation pour autrui dans leurs droits
très bien mais ça n'est pas notre cas et
il ne faudrait pas que on trouve des
moyens de contourner le droit national
au motif de l'intérêt de l'enfant
l'intérêt de l'enfant il doit être
évidemment préserver ses enfants
comptent un état civil ils ont une
filiation mais nous n'avons pas
nécessairement à transcrire ce qui est
pour nous le résultat d'un acte commis
dans l'illégalité qui va contre ce que
nous croyons être un des principes
fondamentaux de la dignité humaine et du
corps des femmes en tant qu à d'origine
et pas de filiation alors pas d'urgence
bien sûr une filiation
encore une fois c'est le choix de ceux
qui ont décidé de pratiquer une gpa de
faire naître des enfants dans cette
situation qui est effectivement une
situation très particulière
nous n'avons pas pour autant à trouver
des moyens dans notre droit de laisser
contourner notre droit lorsqu'ils
touchent à des sujets qui sont si
fondamentaux merci beaucoup merci sophie
pedder merci a lancé xavier bellamy
cette optique le vainqueur politique
avec un marché
[Musique]